[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild
es ist so eine halbstollen Bande sag ich
mal gewesen die haben auch ein anderes
wohl noch Schaden gestiftet ich vom
Boden man hat ihr einen Denkzettel
verpassen wollen und der ist schwer
geworden ein tödlicher Denkzettel der
Vera Maritz auch katzenjühle genannt in
einer dunklen Oktober Nacht des Jahres
2004 das Leben kostet mein Name ist Sky
du Mont und ich begrüße euch zu einer
neuen Episode von Tatort Deutschland
[Musik]
die unscheinbare Frau 66 Jahre alt nur
zierliche ein Meter 63 groß war einsam
und mittellos Vera marotz lebte zusammen
mit ihren geliebten Katzen zurückgezogen
in der kleinen sächsischen Gemeinde
münchwitz nahe Dresden der Rentner
Christfried Seifert dessen 2005
verstorbene Frau Helga die einzige
Kontaktperson von Wera war erinnert sich
während eines Besuchs von BILD-Reporter
Bernhard Schilz an die einsame Frau wir
haben eingehender geredet und das Ding
auch ganz gut aber man müsste wegschauen
wenn man mit ihr redete warum wegen dem
Sturm wenn man so also ihr zugehört hat
oder mit ihr geredet hat dann ging das
halbweg wenn man sie aber angesehen hat
dann ging gar nicht Reporter Bernhard
Schilz und die Bild-Zeitung Dresden
berichten seit Jahren über die
Ermittlungen zum Mord oder dem Totschlag
von Vera marots die Sammlung an Artikeln
über zu Verbrechen füllt einen dicken
Ordner im Dresdner Redaktionsbüro
Bernhard Schills schiebt die randlose
Brille auf der Nase zurecht und blättert
durch die Seiten der ganze Fall ist halt
so emotional weil ich hier eine ältere
Dame die ganz allein auf der Welt war
und eigentlich sich nur um ihren eigenen
Kran gekümmert hat zum Opfer von einer
Gruppe von Schlägern geworden ist und es
gibt eigentlich niemanden der hier für
Gerechtigkeit kämpft oder Gerechtigkeit
fordert Nünchritz eine kleine Gemeinde
bei Riesa unweit von Dresden ist
beschaulich und man lebt hier an der
Elbe nach dem Motto leben arbeiten und
Erholen in münchritz in einer ehemaligen
ddr-plattenbausiedlung hat hier Vera
maroth zusammen mit ihren Katzen gewohnt
klar ist Vera Maros hat es ihr Leben
lang nicht sonderlich leicht sie wurde
in miesebands Pommern im heutigen Polen
geboren nach dem Krieg flüchten sie und
ihre Mutter wie Millionen andere
es verschlägt sie nach Nünchritz seit
dem Tod der Mutter im Jahr 1991 lebte
Vera marots ganz allein zurückgezogen
und als Außenseiterin trotzdem kannte
sie jeder in münchwitz denn Vera maroth
sammelte alles was sie fand sie warf
damals nie etwas weg es wird zu der Zeit
auch gemunkelt dass sie ein Messi und
Sperrmüll in ihrer Wohnung und anderen
Orten Orte
auf ihrer letzten Sammeltour durch den
Ort wurde Vera maroth erschlagen mehr
als 17 Jahre sind seit ihrem gewaltsamen
Tod vergangen Reporter Bernhard Schilz
weiß noch genau wie die Fahndung ganz
klein begann am Anfang war das eine
Polizeimeldung damals im Oktober 2004 wo
man sagt er ist eine ältere Dame neben
der Landstraße gefunden worden da haben
viele gedacht ist die verunfallt war das
vielleicht Fahrerflucht und zwei Tage
später kam dann die erste Meldung die
war auch bei uns noch sehr klein es
scheint ein tragischer Unfall gewesen zu
sein aber dann ändert sich alles als die
Polizei erste Spuren auswertet damals
und auch noch heute mit dem Fall betraut
ist der erste Polizeihauptkommissar der
Dresdner Kripo Frank Haschke wir
ermitteln aktiv in diesem Mordfall denn
mord verjährt nicht der
Polizeihauptkommissar sitzt im schwarzen
Anzug vor den nebeneinander
aufgestellten ermittlungsordnern zum
Fall wäre Marx
er fährt sich mit der Hand durch das
kurze graue Haar dann betrachtet der
nachdenklich die sich auf mehreren Meter
aneinanderreihenden Akten Frank Raschke
erinnert sich wie seine Kollegen das
Opfer auf einer kleinen
verbindungstrasse zwischen Nünchritz und
dem Ort Rödel fanden die Situation
stellte sich folgendermaßen da und das
die Frau Vera marots rücklings auf dem
Straßenrand lag die Spurenlage war
extrem
umfangreich was erst wie ein Unfall
aussieht und nur eine kurze
Polizeimeldung wert ist wird schnell zu
einem Verbrechen zur Mord oder Totschlag
denn die Ermittler rekonstruieren in der
Nacht vom 19 auf den 20 oktober 2004
wird Vera marotz unweit ihres Hauses
brutal getötet wahrscheinlich wird sie
mit Tritten und einem stumpfen
Gegenstand malträtiert bis sie stirbt
ihr Gesicht ist völlig entstellt
Polizeihauptkommissar Haschke ist noch
heute entsetzt Zitat extremst brutal
weil wenn man das vergleicht wie sie auf
dem feindungsfoto aussieht und wie sie
hier in der Sektion dann zu sehen ist
dann merkt man schon welche körperliche
Gewalt dahinter steckte die Frau dazu
zuzurichten wer hat Vera marots die
66-Jährige katzenjule auf eine Straße am
Ortsrand von Nünchritz getötet bis heute
hat die Polizei den oder die Täter nicht
gefasst aber es gibt Anhaltspunkte und
Verdachtsmomente denn in jener Oktober
Nacht geschehen noch mehr Dinge in dem
kleinen sächsischen Dorf
Bildreporter Bernhard Schilz ist erneut
nach Nünchritz gereist um den letzten
verbliebenen bekannten von Vera Marus zu
treffen und sich vor Ort noch mal an
eigenes Bild zu machen noch heute
besucht Christ Fried Seifert häufig das
Grab der mordeten Katzenliebhaberin und
das obwohl der nicht mehr so gut zu Fuß
ist hier erinnern ein schlichtes
steinernes Kreuz und eine Katze aus Ton
an Vera Maros Christ Fred Seifert fragt
sich bis heute wer hat sie getötet das
ist so eine halbstollenbande sage ich
mal gewesen die haben auch ein anderes
würde noch sagen gestiftet ich vermute
man hat ihr einen Denkzettel verpassen
wollen und da ist sie schwer geworden
mit Halbstarken meinte Rentner
Jugendliche aus dem Umland die auf Suche
nach Spaß und vielleicht etwas
Nervenkitzel mit Alkohol und Zigaretten
durch die Gegend Strohmann
an sich nichts schlimmes aber in dieser
Nacht verhängnisvoll denn die Stimmung
bei den Jugendlichen ist aggressiv
einige Anwohner melden noch in der Nacht
Ruhestörungen und Sachbeschädigungen bei
der Polizei das waren zum einen eine
zertrümmerte Frontscheibe eines Pkw Golf
dann wurde ein Stein in eine Scheibe
geworfen des Weiteren haben wir
festgestellt dass ein Seitenspiegel von
einem Fiat Panda
abgetreten wurden die Polizei vermutet
damals dass es sich um eine Gruppe von
bis zu fünf jungen Leuten handelt alle
im Alter ab ca 15 Jahren in der grödeler
Straße fanden die Jugendlichen dann
einen großen Kürbis diesen warfen sie in
die heruntergelassene Jalousie eines
Hauses an der Straße der Krach weckte
natürlich den Bewohner des Hauses er
ruft damals gleich die Polizei der
Anwohner der uns etwa gegen 1:45 Uhr von
dieser Sachbeschädigung informierte
kontrolliert in der Folge auch sein Haus
auf weitere Beschädigungen und er konnte
dabei veramarotz beobachten wie sie an
seinem Haus vorbeiging wir gehen davon
aus dass er der letzte Zeuge war der
wäre maratsleben gesehen hat Rückschau
die Katzenfreundin ist also mitten in
der Nacht mit ihrem Handwagen in der
Gegend unterwegs nicht ungewöhnlich Vera
meidet die Menschen nachts fühlt sie
sich unbeobachtet und sicher
Vera Maros bringt wie immer Sperrmüll
und andere Gegenstände in ihr Lager das
ist ein scheunenverschlag in einem
winzigen ehemaligen Rittergut am
Ortsrand von Nünchritz dort wohnt damals
wie heute der Rentner Günther
wietschorke der wird zwar manchmal
nachts aus dem Schlaf gerissen wenn Vera
marotz mit ihrem Handwagen und
scheppernden Blechteilen auf das
Rittergut kommt aber die beiden haben
sich abgesprochen und so ist es für den
70-Jährigen in Ordnung
später finden Ermittler in dem
scheunenverschlag recht gut geordnete
Möbel und viele kleine Gegenstände keine
zwei Kilometer sind dieser Lagerraum und
ihre Wohnung mit den Katzen voneinander
entfernt Vera marotz war schon fast am
Ziel zwei 300 Meter weiter von Tatort
entfernt ist das alte Rittergut wo sie
ihre Sachen in einem Raum unterbringen
wollte
Bildreporter Bernhard Schilz steht im
eisigen frühjahrswind auf der feuchten
Straße die zu dem kleinen Rittergut
führt wir sind hier auf der groedeler
Straße genau zwischen Nünchritz und
Grödel hier ist tagsüber nicht viel los
nachts noch viel weniger
am 20 oktober 2004 wurde genau hier Vera
Maros ermordet
sie wurde brutal misshandelt mit Dritten
Schlägen gegen Körper und Kopf das hat
die Obduktion später ergeben 2004
titelte Bild nach dem klar ist dass sie
sich nicht um einen Unfall handeln kann
Katzenmutter getötet Mordkommission
ermittelt Kopfgeld Mörder gesucht für
5000 €. helfen Sie mit den Mörder von
Vera marots zu finden die Polizei hat
eigentlich gedacht na ja so eine
marodierende Schlägertruppe findet man
recht schnell da gibt es irgendwo eine
fingerspur so ein Schläger den findet
man doch und sie haben sehr schnell
gemerkt es gibt keine Spur zum Täter die
sächsische Polizei sieht 2004 auch
sofort den Zusammenhang zwischen den
Sachbeschädigungen und dem Mord am
Straßenrand Wera Maritz hatte die
Jugendlichen zufällig beim randalieren
mit dem Kürbis vor dem Haus beobachtet
war das ihr Verhängnis möglicherweise
hat wäre Mauritz eine Person oder
mehrere Personen erkannt und deshalb
wurde sie dann auch angegriffen und in
der Folge auch tödlich verletzt wir
gehen davon aus dass diese
Personengruppe wäre Moritz begegnet ist
und höchstwahrscheinlich auch die Täter
sind aber weshalb wird aus einer
mutmaßlich zufälligen Begegnung ein
brutaler Gewaltexzess wollten die
Randalierer unerkannt bleiben und so
verhindern dass Vera Maritz sie verrät
und sie Probleme zu Hause in der Schule
oder auf der Arbeit bekommen als die
Polizei der Anzeige wegen
Sachbeschädigung nachgehen will und nach
Nünchritz fährt kommen die Beamten
zufällig an der Straße zum kleinen
Rittergut vorbei die Beamten machen den
grausamen Fund für Vera Maros kommt jede
Hilfe zu spät bis heute hat die Polizei
keine Ahnung wer für den grausamen Mord
an Vera marots verantwortlich ist Fakt
ist die Tatzeit konnte auf 1:45
Uhr eingeschränkt werden und genau eine
halbe Stunde zuvor ist Vera marotz hier
auf dieser Straße das letzte Mal lebend
gesehen worden
mit ihrem Handkarren in Richtung Rödel
unterwegs war die Ermittler machen ihren
Job gut finden aber am Tatort keine
knallharten Hinweise auf die Täter erst
bei der Obduktion von verasleiche machen
Sie eine erste erfolgsversprechende
Entdeckung unter den Fingernägeln des
Opfers finden sich DNA-Spuren vor ihrem
Tod muss sie also jemanden festgehalten
oder verzweifelt versucht haben sich zu
wehren mittels dieser gesicherten
DNA-Spur hoffte die Polizei nun den oder
die Täter zu überführen die den
ausspuren wurden zum Teil an der
Bekleidung von Vera Mauritz gesichert
und auch unter den Fingernägeln der
Leiche von wäre Maritz diese DNA-Spuren
unter den Fingernägeln bezog sich auf
eine weibliche Person es kam wieder
Bewegung in die Ermittlung die fahrender
waren motiviert hatte vielleicht eine
Frau Vera marutz auf dem Gewissen das
hätte den Täterkreis halbiert
aber war die Frau vielleicht nur eine
Mitläuferin hatte sie bei der Gewalt hat
nur zugesehen wenn ja wie kann sie bis
heute mit den schrecklichen Bildern von
der wehrlosen Frau leben
die Polizei ermittelt nun fieberhaft sie
suchte jetzt nach einer Frau als
Nünchritz und ernähren Umgebung im Jahr
2005 werden Frauen im Alter zwischen 15
und 40 Jahren aus Nünchritz und Umgebung
gebeten eine Speichelprobe abzugeben man
will einen großen Vergleichstest
vornehmen allerdings ist der freiwillig
Carmen Ermittler Frank Haschke und die
Polizei mit dieser Reihenuntersuchung
der gesuchten Frau auf die Spur in der
Summe wurden dann insgesamt etwa 2500
weibliche Personen dem Test unterzogen
bisher konnten wir keine positive
Zuordnung zu diesen Spuren vornehmen ein
riesiger Aufwand für nichts der Fall
wäre marotz wird zum Cold Case
als Cold Case wird so ein Fall meistens
nach hinten geschoben der neue
dringendere Fälle warten darauf gelöst
zu werden und hinzu kam niemand aus der
Öffentlichkeit machte Druck denn vera
marots hatte niemanden außer ihren
Katzen wir könnten keine Familie von
Vera Moritz ausfindig machen die quasi
die Forderungen an die Polizei stellt
dieses Verbrechen aufzuklären deswegen
ist es für uns ein Ansporn von uns
heraus diese Tat aufzuklären um der
Gerechtigkeit dann Genüge zu tun 2005
startet die Polizei Dresden daher einen
ungewöhnlichen öffentlichen Aufruf um
das Mädchen oder die junge Frau zur
DNA-Spur zu finden Frank Haschke bittet
zusammen mit der Bild-Zeitung die Eltern
oder Personen die diese junge Frau
kennen könnten sich zu melden
haben sie im Oktober 2004 bei ihrer
Tochter ihrem Lehrling ihrer bekannten
Kratzspuren gesehen für die sie keine
Erklärung hatte vielleicht war die junge
Frau selbst schockiert darüber was ihre
Begleiter Taten helfen sie die
Ermittlungen zu verkürzen ich appelliere
an ihr Gewissen und die Strategie von
Polizeihauptkommissar Frank Haschke
scheint aufzugehen in den letzten Jahren
erreichten uns zahlreiche Hinweise wir
haben diese entsprechend unserer
Spurenlage auch verglichen wir konnten
aber reine weiteren Verdachtsmomente
gegen bestimmte Personen wirken
Bildreporter Bernhard Schills hat einen
Verdacht vielleicht kennen die
nünchritzer die Frau deren DNA sich
unter den Fingernägeln der Getöteten
befand und wollen dieses Wissen einfach
verdrängen oder ignorieren gibt es
Menschen die wissen wer dabei war und
sagen sich naja es hatte halt eine alte
Frau getroffen die hatte keine Familie
um die hat keine getrauert die hatte
nichts also kein Grund
für ein Leben lang ins Gefängnis zu
gehen also behalte ich mein Wissen für
mich und auch der Polizist vermutet dass
es Menschen geben muss die seit mehr als
17 Jahren schweigen wir können nicht in
die Köpfe der Täter reinschauen wir
können aber davon ausgehen dass diese
Täter mit dieser Schuld leben müssen und
möglicherweise
irgendwann
diese Belastung nicht mehr aushalten und
sich dann offenbaren auf diesem Punkt
müssen wir hinarbeiten und deswegen
appellieren wir immer an die Bevölkerung
und weitere Hinweise zu geben
dass wir diese Tat aufklären können
der Bildreporter sitzt wieder in der
Küche des Rentners Christfried Seifert
in Nünchritz der Kaffee dampft auf dem
Tisch was denken sie wie kann das sein
dass das Ganze seit 17 Jahren nicht
aufgeklärt ist es gibt ein Gericht dass
derjenige der ihr den täglichen schlagen
versetzt hat sich vom Besucher der
überfahren lassen woher kommt dieses
Gerücht das kann ich im Ursprung auch
nicht sagen vielleicht haben die täteren
der Täter oder die Gruppe solch ein
Gerüchte die Welt gesetzt um von sich
abzulenken oder hat sich der Haupttäter
umgebracht weil er oder sie ein
schlechtes Gewissen hatte
schweigen die möglichen Mitwisser
deshalb hartnäckig
bestätigen will das niemand gegen Tote
wird nicht ermittelt
trinkt seinen Kaffee aus er muss zurück
in die Redaktion und verabschiedet sich
als er mit dem Auto an dem winzigen
Rittergut vorbeikommt sieht er den
Rentner Günther wie tschorke vor der
Scheune auf einer alten Bratpfanne
herumschlagen auf dem gut leben heute
noch viele Katzen Günter sagt dass es
alles wäre es Katzen und deren
Nachkommen sind heute sind sie halb wild
aber wenn er die Bratpfanne schlägt
kommen sie alle angelaufen denn dann
gibt es Futter die Katzen sind alles was
von Vera Maritz geblieben ist
die Fahndung der Mordkommission Dresden
jedoch geht weiter wenn sie in der Nacht
vom 19 zum 20 oktober 2004 Personen
Personengruppen gesehen gehört haben die
mit dieser Tat mit den
Sachbeschädigungen in Verbindung
gebracht werden kann dann wenden Sie
sich an die Polizei wir suchen weiterhin
diese weibliche Person die die Spuren an
veramarotz verursacht hat wir
appellieren an diese Personen sich zu
offenbaren beziehungsweise wir
appellieren an Personen die diese Person
kennen der Polizei Hinweise zu geben so
dass wir
auch diese Straftat aufklären können
wenn ihr also Hinweise habt bitte meldet
euch diese nimmt auch jede
Polizeidienststelle und die
Polizeidirektion Dresden vertraulich
entgegen helft mit den grausamen Mord an
Vera marots aufzuklären ich danke euch
fürs zuhören und dass ihr wieder dabei
wart bei Tatort Deutschland bis zum
nächsten mal euer Sky du
Tatort Deutschland ist eine Produktion
aus den Wakeboard Studios Projektleitung
Simone terbrak Produktion Fabian
Schaeffler Drehbuch Lutz Neumann
Redaktion Bild Bernhard Schulz und
Stefan Netzeband